it's very very exciting I mean this film
has been over two years in the making
and like I'm just ready to have it out
there in the world
it is one of the great disney crown
jewels the fact that we're back here
tonight with this new version it's
unbelievably thrilling the point at
which technology and fairytale can now
meet is so exciting where you can have a
romantic lead character that's
essentially driven by a digital mask
that we create it's mind-blowing we put
a lot of work into this a lot of love a
lot of happy moments are in this film
real sincere happy moments there's
nothing more collaborative than a
musical whether it's a stage physical or
an animated musical and it's really the
quality of the people that you have
around you that makes a little
difference this is why IMAX was built
and Bill Condon the director has created
a movie that is larger than life and
really demands not only the scale that
IMAX has to offer but the sound this is
a musical and you want to hear it with
the best quality sound this is a film
I'm gonna see again and again but I want
to see it in the big theater because if
the technology is unlike anything you've
ever seen before
IMAX works beautifully for this movie
and for love stories which is what this
is so you can sit there in the sweet
spot of this movie and be immersed by it
not only by the picture but by the sound
and have this experience that you can't
get in a normal sized theater
you
[Music]
you